cifras de pérdidas humanas entre las
tropas rusas pueden ser más creíbles y
podría esto desencadenar una reacción
mayor contra la guerra dentro de rusia
en este momento definir una cifra es
imposible en la medida en que se están
desarrollando las operaciones yo diría
que más importante que las cifras es la
necesidad de observar el sostenimiento
el tiempo la operación y la visibilidad
de los bombardeos sobre la ciudad están
significado seguramente unas pérdidas de
vidas civiles abundantes a cualquier
número que se apreció hoy en día sobre
esos registros está determinado por la
necesidad de campañas de información en
todos los lados
y ha podido fallar el cálculo de putin
dada la diferencia de potencial militar
en esta ofensiva cuál es el papel de los
civiles vinculados a las tropas
ucranianas y de los batallones
nacionalistas en conflicto
en términos del desarrollo de la guerra
seguramente los cálculos iniciales eran
una guerra relámpago con unos resultados
rápidos y efectivos cada día que pasa lo
que se genera es un mayor sentimiento
nacional que va a terminar regenerando
la convocatoria de los ciudadanos en
defensa de sus ciudades y en defensa de
su nación claramente se debe de tener
unos efectos terribles y catastróficos
sobre la población ucraniana pero en
términos de la generación de cohesión
alrededor de la defensa de ese país
aumenta el compromiso de sus ciudadanos
y se habla también estos días de la
importancia de mariupol y odessa para la
ofensiva rusa porque son clave estas
ciudades en la conquista de ucrania
porque les da a las tropas rusas el
acceso controlado a todas las costas
sobre el mar
y adicionalmente porque eso les termina
consolidando una de las tenazas que
quieren aplicar sobre el río neverí y
sobre quiere
muchísimas gracias señor restrepo por
este análisis seguiremos atentos